[Music]
jamie otis is getting candid about her
postpartum struggles
you like my hair she thinks just about
it
i see it i like it i want it i got it
the 34 year old married at first sight
star posted
that clip to instagram on monday
revealing she's lost
a lot of hair after giving birth to her
second child in may
a son hendricks who she shares with her
hubby
doug hayner in the caption jaime said
that the experience has
rocked her to the core and has affected
her
emotionally physically and mentally
quote
here i am completely raw and bare and
balding
i have no makeup no filter and you can
totally see my bald spots
i have so much hair loss i feel like i'm
a different person than i was before i
had my son
i've had days where i've been bedridden
too depressed to get up
my daughter says mommy woke up when i
crawl out of bed in the afternoon
jamie and her husband tied the knot on
the first season of married at first
sight in 2014.
do you take jamie otis as your lawfully
wedded wife for now and forevermore
i do and while they are now parents to
five-month-old hendricks and a
three-year-old daughter henley
she suffered several miscarriages over
the years and the reality star said she
hasn't been open about her postpartum
struggles in the past
because she didn't want to seem
ungrateful but now she's working to heal
her body inside and out
i don't want you to think i've got all
my [ __ ] together all the time because
there are definitely days when i don't
but today i feel good tomorrow who knows
the point is body positivity and body
acceptance is not a flip the switch and
it's turned on kind of thing
it's an ongoing personal journey and
this isn't the first time
jamie has opened up about her postpartum
journey i'm gonna miss this bump
when the baby comes out
wait a minute it's been five months and
it's still hanging around
she shared that clip last week writing
in the caption quote
our bodies nurtured life they deserve to
be celebrated
as much postpartum as they are when we
are pregnant
e.t caught up with jamie and doug in
june and they talked about opting to
have an at-home water birth
sans epidural amid the coronavirus
pandemic
to be able to feel every little bit of
him
you know moving inside he's still
kicking as he's coming out like
i could feel his head engage and then
like he like went back up after the
contraction was over i mean i could feel
everything and then when i held him i
mean it was just the most amazing
feeling like we really
bonded not gonna lie though it was very
very painful